the Hatchi has been buried and this Fast
and Furious cast member is roaring back
into the race Dwayne Johnson is set to
headline his very own Fast and Furious
film audiences for fast sex were
delighted to find out that the film's
mid credit scene features a return of
Luke Harps this brief Cameo came after
Johnson publicly made it clear that he
wouldn't be returning for the billion
dollar franchise Now The Hollywood
Reporter confirms that Johnson is on
track to return for a brand new Fast
project which will send to Hobbs and
various other Furious characters why do
I smell baby oil you keep running your
pie hole you're going to smell nice
kicker the outlet knows that this isn't
a sequel to 2019's Hobbs insure the
first spin-off in the fast franchise the
johnson-led project also isn't fast 11.
which Louis La Terrier is expected to
direct instead insiders are describing
it as fast 10.5 is it an entry set
directly after the events of fast X
which saw the fast Farm going up against
their number one hater Dante Reyes or is
Johnson's latest Furious Adventure set
to detail the operation he was leading
at the end of fast X only time will tell
what Johnson and Company have in store
for fans one thing is certain a core
member of the fast family won't be
showing up while other actors from the
franchise are set to reprise their roles
for Johnson's film The Hollywood
Reporter says that Dominic Toretto
active and diesel won't be popping up
Die Hard fans of the franchise will know
that Johnson and Diesel haven't been on
the best terms which was one of the
reasons why Johnson was ready to leave
Hobbs behind him and move on despite
their public Feud lateriere says he
helped convince Johnson to return to the
franchise with the fast X mid credit
scene this time it seems like Johnson
and Diesel have really moved on ready to
bring the fast fam together Johnson said
in a lengthy tweet following the film's
announcement last summer Vin and I put
all the past behind us we'll lead with
Brotherhood and resolve and always take
care of the franchise characters and
fans that we love wasn't that bad having
you work for me
huh
and we all know you're working for me
Hobbs welcome foul Johnson to return to
the franchise in a video accompanying
the Tweet Johnson says that fan
reactions to the character's return made
him realize it was time to return to the
franchise
even when they do in his tweets Dwayne
Johnson teased at his Hobbs movie quote
will serve as a fresh new chapter and
set up for fast X part 2. well this
fresh new chapter include an appearance
by Dante who has a vendetta against
Hobbes while Johnson doesn't explicitly
confirm momoa's return he does say
that's quote business is about to pick
up between the two that has gotta go to
work ultimately concrete details are
slim on this so-called fast 10.5 though
a writer has been found in franchise OG
Chris Morgan he's best known for
planning some other franchises most
memorable films including fast 5 and
Tokyo Drift Morgan also brought the
Hobson Shore spin-off to life though he
didn't return for F9 and fast 10. some
Die Hard fast fans believe that Morgan
is a secret source to the franchise's
success so it's definitely exciting to
see the screenwriter return to the
series Johnson will also be producing
his upcoming Fast and Furious romp
alongside Morgan what's surprising is
that they found a producing partner in
Vin Diesel sitting there that their Feud
is genuinely come to an end that said
details are fairly scarce at the moment
a director isn't currently attached to
the project and according to diesel
faster 11 is set to race into Cinemas in
2025. it remains to be seen if the
hob-centered film will be released
before that
foreign